you
message oh man do not get me
started on the Mexicans hey I just say
it
they hold the goddamn economy together
know what man
damn straight if 12% of the Mexicans
live this country stop working just 12%
USA was shut down I don't even care who
hears me
no they worked our asses off and they
got strong family value essential
immigrants hey speaking of immigrants
how about damn Asians you know what
brother you want to lock that foods and
you better stand back cuz I got
something I want to say about those
I got three words for you
it's studious hardworking industrious
damn straight Asians are the highest
income best educated and the fastest
growing racial group in the US of A
mmm got the highest percentage of
college graduates in the country good
for them maybe this makes me sound
racist but those they're
gonna save the country there it is he
said you went and said it I just said I
just came right the out City it was
it everyone's mine but I'm the one who
said it hey and you know what while
we're at it I'm gonna break my spine
tip-tap dancing wincing prancing around
the elephant in the room blacks
blacks blacks you know what
you're doing doing bed yo nothing fun
gates now I'm a friend
release the Kraken goddamn victims of
institutionalized racism just the big
toe CEOs and
one who's got star dress they're just
true right there that's the story back
mate Katy Margie that oh how about the
Indians Native Americans I don't
know if either give trouble
these days for saying something like
this but they were here first
oh it may be unpopular but it's true we
came to this country and we steamrolled
on in and we genocided them I mean he'll
we hold something are you
I doubt tell me that's not bad for a
non-alcoholic beer and I bet it all all
right I gotta go home take care of my
kids how many of you got now just
adopted the 11th Oh can't help myself me
and that's always what happens when you
volunteer for the earthquake relief in
Haiti what you want let's go dude no my
wife makes 2/3 of what I make what y'all
got the same job man that's just
patently unfair that's right
both librarians nerds you all right I'm
okay